amazon is raising its minimum wage to 15
an hour what's that amazon just what
fifteen dollars an hour fifteen dollars
an hour
fifteen dollars an hour
[Music]
fifteen dollars [ __ ] hour
hi this is what you might call
a get rich quick scammer that is uh they
like to
mock people with nine to five jobs and
tell you that
you should go tell your boss to off
and that's basically it we're gonna walk
through his sales pitch
and get to know more about our our
little friend here
so so stick around what up guys
do you want to easily ditch your nine to
five and make six figures a year
working only one day a week from your
laptop
i know i sure do who is this mysterious
man
who's laughing at the idea of a nine to
five job
right because everyone who works nine to
five jobs they're losers
losers work for a living are you kidding
me dude
adrian g is his name and unbelievably
dope that's a lot of subscribers okay
this guy's popular it seems like all the
popular people are hopping on selling
get rich products right they love it
they love
selling to their gullible fans their
little fantasies
so he's selling something called six
figure sunday
i guess that's the day you're supposed
to work one day a week to make six
figures now if that doesn't already
sound preposterous
i mean i know it already does so hold on
though hold on don't click off
i know it sounds preposterous but you
won't believe what this guy says
you'll be wondering why haven't the
police knocked on this guy's door
seriously it's unbelievable what this
guy tries to
hoodwink people with and the fact that
no one's caught him out on it is
honestly insane 1.79 million
subscribers and he's hocking this crazy
stuff
so let's get into what he's promising
what he's guaranteeing so we've already
uh gone through him
mocking people who work for a living but
let's see that again real quick
oh 15 an hour
fifteen dollars an hour
you you work for a living but later he
tries to redeem himself
because he basically insults you right
out the gate he tries to redeem himself
you're worth
100 200. three five hundred dollars an
hour
okay so this is a smart play basically
he's like look if you're not making 500
bucks an hour
like you're worth it you're worth it
boss babe go get what you're worth
he's saying that it's on you if you're
not making that kind of money maybe
you you're missing the secret right and
i'm going to show you
exactly how to achieve that today
i am going to show you how to make six
figures working from the
beach but before i show you how to make
six figures a year by working just
one day a week from your laptop let me
tell you a little about
who the hell i am are you getting dude
who the hell i am nobody cares who the
hell you are
why is he looking so intensely at the
camera
he's got that like open
close it just pipe down nobody cares who
you are okay you may have 1.79
million subscribers so technically
people already know who the hell you are
but
we don't care the coffeezilla army we
don't respect people like you
my name is adrian grushka but for sure
you can simply call me
adrian g and over the past five years
i've worked nothing but one day a week
i worked a nine to five just like you
and you and you
and you i love the content in his face
when he's doing this
he's like hey i used to be a loser like
you guys
you attack support loser guy
you can't see this guy driving a bus
loser guy doing construction work
loser have you thought about selling get
rich quick games get rich quest games
oh that that is just something i can't
stand in this industry i'll let this
play more in a second but
the belittling of actual work while you
sit around here and promise
empty dreams to people is so disgusting
dude
i am sickened by this i'm sickened
by this belittling of real jobs dude
it's
one of the things that drives me most
crazy about this disgusting
world of get rich quick schemes is it's
icky through
years and years of what i politely
define as hell
one day oh you thought he wasn't he
wasn't belittling it
you tell something just clicked i
snapped and finally had enough
so for the second time i'm going to skip
ahead here a little bit and say that he
gives you the whole sob story right
he goes he says that he used to work
nine to five jobs just like
yeah and yeah and yeah
and yeah right he he did that whole sub
story he says my boss he fired me
it's he was such a jerk whatever then i
basically found the secret right
he's gonna talk about he was destitute
he was he was about to be homeless he
said
and uh one day he was trying to figure
out
what is he good at are guys finally
going to tell us what the secret is
what's his skill what
what was his big epiphany there had to
be
something i was good at something where
i could give
value to the world that i was actually
passionate about
and that's when i received a text
message from one of my lady friends
amber
that said hey babe what you up to buckle
up boys
and that's when i had my money-making
epiphany
this is what he's passionate about he's
very passionate about amber trust
you see amber was a girl i met at the
grocery store got her number and have
been having some
fun with her ever since and she was just
one of many
many girls on my roster all my guy
friends would always ask me
how the hell do you pull so many girls
so easily
i would simply smile shrug my shoulders
and say
i have no idea i just sort of do my
thing
dude imagine talking about yourself and
be like
all my guy friends are like dad how you
slay so much dude
how do you get so many girls and i'm
just like i don't know it's just sort of
something i do
but this is when i realized that i
do have a skill and not just a skill but
a skill that would be
valuable to other people which is the
key
so while i could never go to school to
be a dentist or a surgeon per se
i guess you could just call me the love
doctor dude
the love doctor
what how i
so i swear guys sometimes i really do
think to myself
why isn't everybody in the world talking
about this where's pewdiepie
dude this is the best content ever the
love doctor
i swear when you guys say coffee's
always having too much fun you're
actually right it's criminal
how much fun that i'm having but anyways
love doctor guys
practicing without a license doctor
because i was as good at picking up
chicks as any man walking
earth but the thing is while i had
all the knowledge and secrets in the
world on how to help guys pick up women
there was still no way i could create my
own product and package it within two
weeks before
i was out of my ass from this eviction
notice oh yeah sorry guys uh i
we gotta skip past this it's just like
the boring
sob story about how he was just like you
he was about to be evicted from his
apartment that's to get your emotions
all
you know stirred up oh magically he
figured it out he mastered it
and that's his way of trying to get you
to
follow him because you think to yourself
oh i was just like this guy i'm in a bad
spot
maybe he's holds the secret it's a
classic copywriting tool
okay so now he's gonna get into the
pitch he's gonna start selling selling
selling and this is where it gets
truly disgusting powerful detailed easy
to use program
ever created on how to generate a six
figure revenue
working just one day a week guaranteed
this isn't a program filled with cheesy
get rich quick schemes for you to follow
no oh
my gosh how do these people say that
with a straight face without without
doing this
[Applause]
your program is literally called six
figure sunday
in which you teach people to make six
figures working one day a week if that's
not a get rich quick
program i don't i don't know what is i
mean look
you're the love doctor right i'm
coffeezilla you're the love doctor i'm
coffee
i i specialize in get rich quick schemes
i'm sorry to say buddy we've
uh done the math
it's a get rich quick scheme i mean
that's what it is so anyway now he's
going to talk about uh how bosses are
evil
again right because he really needs to
sell you and after i get fired
i almost get evicted and end up homeless
honestly now that i look back on it
living like that and letting another man
have so much power over me
actually made me less of a man
it's just something i have to admit this
you're such a scumbag dude
why he's doing this is because he's
telling you at home hey
if you have a boss you're really kind of
you're kind of a baby boy
are you a baby boy if you don't have my
program you're a baby boy
because if you let i have a boss have
that kind of power over you dude
doesn't that make you less of a man
i don't know there's this guy's so
shameless at this point if i'm being
real with myself
and besides my boss being the world's
biggest douchebag
going into work five days a week just to
make enough money to live
wasn't too fun in its own right just an
outright
dead-end job with no extra time or money
for leisure while
all the ceo does is kick back on his
luxury yacht sipping five thousand
dollar bottles of champagne off of
my blood sweat and tears
again this guy is so
out to lunch dude that's why i'm gonna
call bs on him probably ever having a
job
who thinks their boss is doing this dude
most ceos are working their tail off
i mean i know it's a meme that they sit
back with like their fat cats
and yeah they get paid a lot but they're
not sitting
on yachts all day sipping five thousand
dollar bottles of champagne
this is such a cringe
trope that these people try to do oh
your boss is just
he's just sitting on the yacht doing
nothing why is he even there when you're
you're doing everything such a dumb view
of how jobs work
and i want to reiterate again i'm sure
you've seen
other make money programs out there
claiming to help you make
100 million dollars or make 50k in just
seven days
but this is the difference i'm not here
to give you false bs expectations and
sell your dreams
no i can't help you make 50k in only
seven days and no i don't guarantee
you'll be able to make
100 million dollars but what i can
promise is
you will be able to make six figures a
year working just one day a week
which is more than what most humans
could ever ask for
if you're looking to be the next hey
bill gates or jeff bezos hey you can't
do it shut up
shut your mouth shut shut your mouth
when i'm talking hey
hey you can't you can't do that
that's illegal it should it should be
illegal all right
that that's illegal to do what you just
did
hey i'm not i'm not here to promise you
get rich quick schemes right hey i'm but
i what i can promise you is that you can
work one day a week and make six figures
dead
this isn't some kind of crazy get rich
quick game am i right guys
[Music]
this guy
oh my gosh
i've lost it dude i've lost the plot
okay let's get let's get back into this
to be honest in this economy
i had oh i actually i actually know what
part is coming up oh you guys are going
to love this
oh my gosh dude this may be my the
greatest
get rich quick scheme video of all time
but can we get some light in here it's
kind of bothering me hold on one second
a rich
go ahead sorry i'm sorry they interrupt
you originally planned to give this
system away for
absolutely free that is until i realized
such a move would turn out to be
counterproductive
really you plan to give it away for free
i wanted to give it away for free but
it'd be counter i have to charge you
guys
and ruin the mission of what i actually
set out to do
which is helping you make six figures on
your own
let me explain please do you see
if everyone were to download this system
for free
the system and skills it teaches would
go viral
instantly why is this a bad thing
because once it goes viral all the other
blogs
will steal my powerful secrets and
rebrand as a get rich quick scheme doc
it is a get rich quick scheme i don't
know what to tell you
it is one remember i'm the get rich
quick scheme doctor
and that's when all the lazy posers will
attempt to use the system while
you the serious one will pass over
because you
think it's just another bs system like
all the other crap floating around out
there this is such a pathetic attempt
to hide the real reason he just wants to
make money hey
that's the reason he's not some altruist
he's not trying to give you secret
powerful magical formulas out of the
kindness of his heart
so after some careful deliberation i was
able to pull some strings
and strike the perfect balance on the
cost of the system
to ensure i was able to really pull hey
i'm out there fighting for you i told
the people above me who made the course
me i told them you can't charge them
this much
i swear dude it's unethical to charge
them this much they're broke they need
help
but at the same time we have to charge
them because otherwise it would be it'd
be go viral instantly we wouldn't want
that
so i told myself you better give them a
good price every person
in need of ditching their boss and
making six figures a year
could easily afford it so today
for a limited time you can access the
six-figure sunday system
instantly for a one-time fee of just
497 which is 78 off
the normal price of 2197
and once you get your hands on the six
figure sunday system
it's going to be like sticking the key
in the ignition of a brand new
lamborghini guys don't
don't forget this is not a get rich
quick scheme it's not
once you get it it is like sticking the
keys in the ignition of a brand new
lamborghini but remember guys this
isn't like the other crap floating
around out there in fact that's why he
has to charge you 497 dollars for it
truthfully
and that's that's that's the end he goes
and sits down
at his desk while wearing board shorts i
guess to show that oh wow he
this guy's such a rock star dude he
doesn't even wear pants
i mean honestly i'm not impressed that
used to be original before covet now
i mean it's original to wear pants right
like now
i'm the original one actually out here
wearing pants
oh and then get this he starts counting
money gosh that's so loud
so aggressive
so one last thing i want to talk about
before we go like i know you already
think he's a scumbag but
look one thing he harps on one thing he
makes painfully clears oh my gosh i'm
such a good guy
for offering you a guarantee and by that
he means he has a money back guarantee
which most people in the get rich space
have actually how this works the little
insider secret is they have a
calculation for eve they know
almost nobody this is gonna happen for
nobody nobody's gonna be working one day
a week and getting six figures right so
they know that but they also know that
not everyone who fails
will get a refund just just odds so they
just count on
most people not asking for a refund
that's how they make their money but
nonetheless he really tries to hit home
that man he's such a good guy
biggest companies 100 billion one
trillion dollar companies like best buy
and amazon
only offer a measly 15 and 30 day
guarantee respectively
but that's that greedy ceo corporate bs
laughing at you again go figure go
figure i adrian grushka little
me is willing to double quadruple their
guarantee window
because i have zero down no you're a lot
i'm not even gonna let you finish this
lie
okay he says oh man i'm double their
offer he says that he's got a 60-day
money-back guarantee refund okay let's
take that apart first of all i've
already explained to you that that's
part of their calculation right
but secondly it's standard for clickbank
clickbank at its discretion will allow
for the replacement or return of
any product within 60 days of purchase
stop pretending like you're the good guy
that's just their standard return policy
hey you you probably would have tried to
get around it if you could
i mean don't act like you're some good
guy oh that's that greedy corporate bs
bro you were forced to offer a refund so
shut your mouth oh wait there's more
actually hey check out what i just found
this is the six figure sunday's terms of
service oh
let's look at this updated january of
2019
okay so let's see here uh the refund
oops looks like we've got a 30-day
refund
interesting and then it's actually an
action-based refund
so you have to looks like you have to
create a landing page that gets a
thousand visits which
isn't easy to do but then check out the
little note
where this greedy corporate bs guy he
doesn't do that
look at what he does due to the
tremendous value throughout the course
you will not be eligible for a refund if
you
purchased the six figure sunday at a
discount price
so what does that mean ladies and
gentlemen this guy who says i'm not
gonna do the corporate bs
well it means that no one who buys his
product is eligible
for any refund this guy
who this guy this guy right here
won't offer you a refund look at this
guy easily
15 and 30 day guarantee respectively
but that's that greedy ceo corporate bs
laughing at you again go figure i
adrian grushka little old me is willing
to
double quadruple their guarantee window
because i have zero down my mind that
six figure sunday will work for you bro
you literally wrote it in the fine print
that nobody's gonna read and you know it
that you actually can't get a refund you
lying hypocrite
that's that greedy corporate big ass dad
oh man this guy is the gift that keeps
giving so
anyways guys um i hope you enjoyed this
video
and uh you know i don't know
subscribe smash like while you do that
i'll uh
be counting counting my money uh i
actually don't have any money around it
let me just let me just let him count
them
aggressively count the money for me just
just join the six figure coffeezilla
club right
six figures we're at 180k subs let's see
if we can
crank that up huh all right see you next
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
time
[Music]
you